thank you very much thanks so much
welcome to the oscars
uh for those of you watching around the
world it has been a tough couple of days
for us here
it has been raining
we're fine thank you for your prayers
i am happy to be back i hosted seven
years ago and i am so honored and
flattered that they have me back so
quickly
things are so different now uh last time
for instance when i was here cate
blanchett was nominated meryl streep was
nominated
leonardo dicaprio was nominated martin
scorsese was nominated so different
there are some first-time nominees here
tonight june squibb is nominated for
nebraska
at 84 years old she is the oldest
nominee she was wonderful in nebraska
i'm telling everyone that you are
wonderful in nebraska
the film that you did wonderful
we have other first time nominees lupita
nyong'o is here
amazing
amazing uh amazing performance in 12
years a slave
she is from kenya she is a kenyan and uh
barcad abdi is here he is nominated for
captain phillips
he's from somalia he is a sommelier so
he knows a lot about wine and that is
impressive
who's the wine captain now
who's the lion captain now
the real captain phillips is here
tonight and the real philomena is here
tonight
and
and i have to say one of the most
amazing liza minnelli
impersonators i have ever seen in my
entire life
just uh really seriously
good job sir i mean that is really
tonight's theme is heroes in hollywood
and we need heroes now more than ever
people around the world are going
through hard times and movies
offer us an escape movies inspire us
i'm not saying that movies are the most
important thing in the world because we
all know that the most important thing
in the world is youth
now we know that the most important
thing in life is love
and friendship and family and if people
don't have those things well then
they usually get into show business so
here we all we're big one big frightened
family is what we are but
i want you to know that i love you and i
think you're talented i do
and i think you should think of
yourselves as winners not all of you but
the people who have won before should
think of yourselves
as winners and i know what you're
thinking ellen that's easy for you to
say you've been chosen to host and
that's sort of the highest award there
is
thank you
thank you
but let's try to focus on you tonight if
we can seriously the work that you've
done is incredible and i did a little
bit of research and between
all of the nominees here tonight you've
made over 1400 films
1400 films and you've gone to a total of
six years of college
i'm kidding kids stay in school i'm sure
these people went to college
i mean amy adams you went to college
right
no okay well who cares you're an amazing
actress you're not
not one but two nominated films tonight
you were in that's just um
that is so what is the word for it
selfish
i guess
i really do think it's an exceptional
year for movies uh of course one of the
nominees is
her and by her i mean meryl streep
meryl has been nominated for an oscar a
total of 18
times
no it sounds good but if you do the math
between dresses hair and makeup that's
hundreds of thousands of dollars
simply put meryl cannot afford to be
nominated again that is
a lot of money
i'm listing all these people like you're
up against each other and you're also
talented i don't want you to think of
as any kind of a competition it's a
celebration
although who are we kidding it's the
hunger games i mean there are cameras
everywhere you're starving jennifer
lawrence won last year
it is the hunger games
jennifer by the way i am not going to
bring up what happened last year when
you were
you know
it's ridiculous i mean you something
like that happens and it's embarrassing
and then people just talk about it and
it's just you know
for those of you who don't know what i'm
talking about when
last year she fell on the way up tripped
i don't know if she got caught on the
dress let's just show the clip because
what happened
i'm kidding i'm not going to show the
clip
i'm kidding i am i i'm not
i'm not but let's just and you know the
thing when you fell out of the car
tonight when you were getting out of the
car no one needs to know that i am not
going to mention that
she fell on the way out of the car
like on an orange cone you tripped or
something
if you win tonight i think we should
bring you the oscar i don't want to risk
we can do that right can we do that no
one's there
win or lose you look beautiful you all
look beautiful tonight sandy you look
beautiful and
and kate you look everybody looks
beautiful i'm not going to say who looks
the most beautiful
but let it's it's clear it's jared leto
i mean he's the prettiest
boy is he pretty i mean he's uh
nominated for best supporting actor and
matthew mcconaughey
also pretty by the way but a different
like a rugged dirty
a dirty pretty like a dirty city
no good dirty not bad dirty both
nominated for dallas buyers club a very
important movie
it deals with a serious issue of people
who have sex at rodeos
don't do it it looks appealing but
speaking of sex at the rodeos bruce
stern is here tonight
i had a i just needed a transition i
have no idea
a little background on bruce his
grandfather was the governor of utah
his great uncle was a pulitzer
prize-winning poet and his godmother was
eleanor roosevelt
and here you are among us tonight what
went wrong
jonah hill is nominated for his amazing
performance in wolf of wall street
that
honestly i have to say you showed us
something in that film that i have not
seen for a very very long time
well we should get started it's going to
be an exciting night
anything can happen so many different
possibilities possibility number one 12
years a slave wins best picture
possibility number two you're all
racists